[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Hi,
and welcome to episode
number 188 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
I'm Mark Mirchandani
and I'm here
with my colleague Brian Dorsey.
Hey, Brian.
BRIAN DORSEY: Hello.
And we've had a really good
conversation here today
with Priyanka about
conversation AI-- kind of meta.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh,
it's super, super cool.
But before we get into that,
we also have our question
of the week, which talks a
little bit more about running
Python scripts-- or
really any other script--
in a very recurring manner.
BRIAN DORSEY: Awesome.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: But before
even we get into that--
I like all these befores.
It's very confusing about
where we are in the show,
as though people hadn't
realized what the structure was.
Well, before we do
that, we do want
to talk about our cool
things of the week.
BRIAN DORSEY: So I work
in serverless and compute
for developers in general.
And we mostly focus on trying
to make it easy and smooth
and reliable to run stuff.
But we also need
to keep it secure.
And so there was an
article on the GCP
out recently on how to
execute the principle of least
privilege when building a
system in Cloud Functions.
So I just want to plug
that a little bit.
I think it's pretty interesting.
And at the core, it's basically
using a service account
dedicated for each
function and then
giving it specific
permissions on your project.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
I mean, these resources
are easy to spin up
and easy to manage.
So it kind of makes
sense that you
might create an
individual service
account for each
function and then
be really, really granular
about the permissions
those accounts have.
BRIAN DORSEY: And this is
a relatively new feature
for functions, but it
is definitely there now.
So used to be the case
that all functions were
under one service account.
And so now you can make
much more granular controls.
And we've got a link to
introducing it and going
into more detail in the notes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And
speaking of using functions
to do kind of cool things,
there's a fantastic blog post
that I just saw about
spinning up a Minecraft
server using functions to
send the triggers for starting
and stopping the server,
using Compute Engine to host
the actual server, and
using some backups.
But I think what makes
this really, really cool
is that this little blog post is
targeted towards having a child
start to understand some of
these architecture pieces.
And maybe as parent-child
thing, you can both work on it
and kind of spin up
a Minecraft server,
which I think is super fun.
Because we've seen
a lot of examples
of previous architectures
involving Minecraft
in the past, but
this is a fun way
that you can kind
of take something
that most kids care a lot
about, which is Minecraft,
and try to get into showing
them the architecture version.
And it even has a fun little
child architecture diagram,
which I completely adore.
But it's a very
cute and very fun
way to showcase a
simple architecture.
And then it gives you
a lot of ideas of what
you might build on top of that.
For example, a common one
is how do you make sure
that there's sort of a curfew
set up so that the server shuts
down?
Well, again, that's something
you can do with functions.
BRIAN DORSEY: That's
super interesting,
and I think applicable to a lot
of work environments as well.
So that's a lot of fun.
Actually, that reminds me--
I think several years
ago, a colleague of ours,
Julia Ferrioli, wrote
a series of posts
about containerizing
Minecraft and running it
on Google Kubernetes engine.
So let's include a
link to that too.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So that
might be the next step
after Compute Engine is you
teach your child containers
and then show them
Minecraft in that.
BRIAN DORSEY: You can
never start too early.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I believe you can.
And I would not want to be
the person teaching containers
to a middle school group.
But you know what,
actually, I think
a lot of people on our team are
doing that and props to them.
And I think--
maybe you're right.
Maybe you can't start too early.
And they get these concepts
a lot faster than I did.
BRIAN DORSEY: That's super fun.
OK, so another cool
thing of the week
that I think is keeping in
tune with the overall theme
for our main topic is around AI.
And we just recently
announced a What-If Tool
for cloud AI platform models.
So there's this
on-running understanding
that one of the challenges
for working with ML
is actually understanding
what's going on in the covers
and how the model's
making decisions.
So there's this tool, What-If,
that has worked with TensorFlow
and now works with a
few other very common ML
back ends and works
with AI platforms
that are running on GCP
or on your own machines
to help you understand how the
model is making its decisions.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So it lets
you kind of investigate,
I guess, by the
name-- what if you
were to change some
certain aspects of it
or how you can kind of look at
it from a more holistic view
and kind of ask more
intelligent questions?
Is that right?
BRIAN DORSEY:
Yeah, exactly that.
And for example, give
you a visualization
of the distribution
of where things land.
And when you click
there, you can
see where the model made
a different decision
for similar cases.
So you can really get down to
the details of why something
turns out a certain way or not
and help the model from there.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, I can definitely
say that I would rather teach
a large class about containers
than I would about AI.
BRIAN DORSEY: As a person coming
from a compute perspective,
I would be a lot more
successful that way as well.
All of those words I just said
were from the blog post that
is linked in the show notes.
So with that.
Is it time to get into it?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I think we should.
Let's go ahead and jump into
our interview with Priyanka.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK, here we are.
I'm Brian Dorsey here today
with Mark and Priyanka Vergadia.
Go ahead.
Could you introduce
yourself and what you do?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Sure, yeah.
So I am a developer
advocate at Google Cloud.
And I've been working with
customers and partners
on conversational AI use
cases for quite some time.
So I'm really
excited to be here.
BRIAN DORSEY: So conversational
AI-- what is that?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Conversational AI
or conversational experiences--
it's basically a
comprehensive name
for a newer class of solutions
that include chat bots, voice
bots--
experiences that are
basically conversational
based, so whether it's
in apps or messengers
and things like that.
The common denominator
is basically
the use of natural
language understanding
and natural language
processing, which is obviously
a type of AI technology,
to power these interactions
between humans and machines.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So let's
take it a step back there.
Tell us what natural language
understanding really means.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Absolutely.
So in very simplistic terms,
natural language understanding
is a technology that helps
translate human language
into computer language--
and also vice versa.
So let's think about
this as an example.
So when you and I-- when
two humans are talking
to each other, if we speak
in the same language,
we don't need a translator.
But if I speak English and
you speak, say, Spanish,
and I don't understand
Spanish and vice versa,
then we need a
translator in the middle
to translate my
English to Spanish
and then your
Spanish to English.
Same way when humans are talking
that human language needs
to be translated to a computer,
because a computer speaks
binary--
0's and 1's.
So our English needs
to translate into those
0's and 1's.
And then the computer
responds back.
Then that binary needs
to be translated back
into English as well.
So that technology can be called
natural language understanding.
And then while we are at it,
natural language processing
is also worth mentioning.
Because natural
language processing
is a superset of this realm,
where natural language
understanding falls in it.
And natural language
processing includes
things like, how do you
paraphrase something?
Or how do you summarize
a given story?
Or how do you
understand sentiments
off of a conversation?
Or was there a spelling
mistake or an error or accent
changes and differences
and things like that?
So that is what natural language
understanding and processing
means.
And it's kind of the core of
conversational AI technology.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
So this is more than just
speech to text, then?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yes.
It's absolutely much
more than speech to text.
Like I said, when you talk about
natural language processing,
speech to text is
one part of it.
There is natural
language understanding,
which is the other part.
And then you hear things
like text to speech
is another part of it.
And then you'll also hear
automatic speech recognition,
which is ASR.
So these are kind
of different parts
of the technology that
fall under natural language
processing.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
we've got a way for people
to talk and understand
what they're saying.
And that's kind
of one side of it.
But then you dive deeper
into it with things
like sentiment and understanding
what they're saying--
even going so far as to
summarize what they're saying,
because you're able to pull out
these very abstract concepts
and then define them and say, I
think when this person mentions
something about the Eiffel
Tower, for instance,
I know what that is.
I know where it is.
I know it's this landmark.
And I can use that
information to pull together
something else-- whatever
that workflow might be.
Going back to what you
were saying earlier
about chat bots, on
a website, usually
there's a pop-up or
something and then
you can kind of converse
with, in this case, an AI.
So this is something
new or interesting.
We've been talking about
robo chat for a while,
but this is more
about actual AI.
Why is this big?
And what's happening now that's
making this more prevalent
than it used to be?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
The world that we're
living in now with more
and more devices that
are coming online these days--
whether it's IoT or
just our preference
of dealing with more devices
and working with more devices--
take an example.
You wake up in the morning
starting from a smart coffee
maker to when you end
your day with asking
Google to set your alarm.
You deal with so many
devices in the day.
And it's going to
be, and it already
is, becoming really difficult
to deal with all the devices
and work with them
on a smart screen.
We are going to have to have
conversations with our machines
and devices as we
progress in this era
where we have more
and more devices.
Just an example-- when you're
having breakfast or cooking
breakfast and you
want to know what's
the traffic to the office, you
don't want to look at a screen.
You just want to know
the answer to that.
So that's just one
example, but that
goes to say that we
are moving in the era
where dealing with machines is
becoming our everyday pattern
and every minute pattern.
And for those
reasons, most people
are interested in having their
problems solved with voice
and conversational interfaces.
BRIAN DORSEY: So this is
showing up in a bunch of places.
You mentioned chat
bots, and we've
got these kind of boxes you
see on support for websites--
to talk to maybe a home
or other assistant thing
in the morning for weather
and traffic and such.
Are these the most
common use cases,
or are there other things?
What are people actually
doing with this today,
and what do you see
them doing next?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
So I just gave the broad
examples with the traffic
pattern and alarms and such--
and smart coffee makers.
But what companies
or enterprises
are using conversational
AI for are
use cases around customer
experience and customer
support.
And it's very easy to
start with that use case.
It's because of
the fact that you
know a very specific
pattern of questions
that your customers would
ask or your users would ask.
So it's the lowest barrier to
entry into conversational AI.
And examples could include--
for example, if you
talk about retail,
that customer experience could
be a personal shopper, where
I want to know a specific type
of outerwear I'm looking for.
And then this personal
shopper can give me
recommendations on here are
some of the different sizes
and colors and party wearers
versus others and things
like that.
And I actually built a demo
around that a few weeks ago.
And then the other
example could be
in banking or in
financial institutions
where, really, when
you go to a teller,
you ask questions like,
what's my balance,
or I want to withdraw
an amount, or I
want to transfer an amount from
this account to this account.
And you can do all
of that through chat
or a conversational experience.
So those are some
of the easy ways
to kind of get into it
and also the best place
to start, because you know
what the user is asking for
and you know how to respond to
it because your back-ends are
already supporting
that with your websites
or in a more
personalized manner.
So you can put
those two together
into a conversational experience
by using a natural language
understanding or
processing platform
like the one we're going to
talk about, which is Dialogflow.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Don't worry-- we'll
mention Dialogflow for you.
But I wanted to pick up
on some of the topics you
were saying there.
With customer support
being probably one
of the premier examples
of this and basically
just taking that conversation
piece and automating it--
because there's a huge subset
of the users that call in
or they contact support.
And I'm sure there's some
percentage out there.
I'll make one up and say 98%
can be solved through routing it
through three simple kind of
formula questions that are FAQs
or what have you.
But then the people who do
kind of get through that
and when they do get to
usually a live human agent,
they'll at least have a
little bit more information
on what the context is.
So there's this
great kind of balance
between not having to be on
hold as long because you don't
have to wait for a person.
Many people can interface with
a machine at the same time
and not have to overload it.
But we've seen implementations
of these things
for a long time, right?
The automated phone
support system
has been around
for quite a while.
And I speak for myself
and maybe popular media
when we say like, oh, these
are so frustrating sometimes.
And they're so rigid.
And you're just like, I need
this piece of information,
but the machine
won't let me have it.
Or it needs these 80 things
that are not related.
It's very cool.
It's very interesting.
But it can also be
incredibly frustrating.
I would hope that a lot of
this stuff is changing it.
But I'm sure there's been
lots of failure cases as well.
Where does the
challenge lie in this?
Where do the problems happen?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah, I
think the biggest thing that
needs to be thought
about are why
conversational interfaces have
failed or do actually fail
even today.
There is a really good
compiled list, chatbots.fail,
and it's definitely
worth checking out.
But I'm going to
highlight a few here.
Some of the reasons why
chat bots actually fail
is the rigid structure--
the flow charts.
They're really designed for
how the machine responds
and what the
machine's looking for,
not how the human
would say something.
And that is where the
biggest problem is.
So what we need to
do in order to create
a good natural
experience is to use
natural language,
obviously-- natural language,
understanding, and
processing-- where
you can have the
machine understand
what the user is saying and then
decide what needs to be done.
Versus in the IVR
examples that are
frustrating that you
mentioned, Mark, we
went the other way around.
We are basically designing
an IVR by saying, OK,
I will only take a customer
account information.
And if they don't give me
the account information,
I'm going to keep saying,
can you say that again?
Can you say that again?
And that is what
makes it frustrating,
because there is no
understanding that the customer
doesn't have that.
So I can ask for
these other things.
I'll give you a very simple
example where if I say,
would you like coffee, and the
IVR is expecting yes or no,
and if I said, sure, it's gone.
It's gone wild,
because it doesn't know
that "sure" also means a yes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I got to be honest.
In the mornings when I
need coffee, even yes or no
is asking a lot.
If I could just kind of
unintelligibly grunt towards it
and it's like, yeah,
he needs coffee,
that would be preferable.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
So that's what I'm alluding to.
And that's the
advancement in technology
that we are utilizing with
natural language understanding
and processing.
So that's definitely one.
And then some of
the others are you
need to make sure that your
back-end is actually properly
integrated with your front-end.
So you can have the very best
natural language understanding
experience, but if your
back-ends or your databases
cannot connect properly to
respond to these questions,
then again that experience
is not going to be useful.
So in this case,
let's take an example
and say you connect
to Salesforce back-end
where you create these
tickets or questions
that the user comes with.
And you create a
case in Salesforce.
But the hook of the API that
needs to make that connection
is either not live or you
don't have the right way
of making that connection.
Then it's not going to be a
really good and streamlined
experience.
So making sure that the
back-end can connect
is another very big example.
And then some others
could be creating
a chat bot that is a silo.
And it only does this one thing
and doesn't do the other five
things that it should be doing.
So if somebody asks a question
about the other five things
that are not handled, then how
do you handle them in that bot?
It's OK to not
have them handled--
not have the answers
to those questions--
but it's not OK to
leave the user thinking,
what they are supposed to do.
So you need to provide them
something to go off of.
BRIAN DORSEY: I have
a related question
around this exact thing.
So if we think about
GUI versus command line,
we kind of think that the
visual user interfaces
are more discoverable.
You can kind of figure out
what's possible or not,
but you have to do the
same thing every time.
And command lines, it's not easy
to figure out what's possible,
but once you do, you
kind of internalize
that and you can do
things very quickly,
or you can make scripts
to do things in order.
And I feel like we're
almost missing how
to think about these things.
And in particular for voice--
as a user, I find this question
of not even knowing what's
possible really challenging.
I don't know what I
can say or not say
to the thing I'm talking to.
And it gets frustrating
after a while.
As people are interested
in designing these,
do you have
recommendations for how
to help with that challenge?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yes.
So the first and the biggest
recommendation that we offer
when we help design these
experiences is when the user
ends up on your bot experience
or on your chat experience--
however they are ending up
on that landing prompt--
that prompt should be
very specific in terms
of what this bot can do.
So when my bot responds back
saying, hi, welcome to XYZ,
I can help you get your balance
information and transfer funds
from one account to another--
and if it does only
these two things,
then mention those two things.
If there's any other
questions that they have,
at least the user now
knows that the bot
can do these two things.
BRIAN DORSEY: Is this
like the rest of life?
Like, setting expectations
is everything?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Exactly, right?
So just make sure that you're
setting those expectations
correctly.
And obviously they're going
to ask questions that you
didn't expect them to ask.
And then for those, you
have the fallback mechanism
where you say, OK, I
didn't understand that,
but a connection to a
human being or a live agent
is also very critical.
There are going to be scenarios
where your bot will not
know what to do, because it's
not programmed to do that.
In those cases, how you
connect to a live agent--
whether it's chat or a call--
is important.
And you need to figure
that out as well
while you're building the bot.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I mean, for command lines,
we've got like Tak Tak Help.
So usually you have
this verbose list
of all the things you can do.
But in conversing with
AI, it doesn't exist.
Is that something
that people have tried
and it just didn't work?
Is that something that just
doesn't resonate with people?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: I had
a conversation with one
of our voice-user
interface designers
at Google a few days ago.
And she brought up a
very interesting point.
She said, we all
assume that we know
how to have a conversation.
And that's why we start
building a bot without creating
any blueprints.
And that is the biggest problem.
And she kept mentioning
and highlighting the fact
that you need to build
the design flows.
They're not flowcharts.
They are the flows
where you say,
here are the 1,000 ways in
which people can ask for coffee.
And understandable
that machine learning
is going to handle
all those 1,000 ways,
but you still need to
think how the flow will
traverse when they are asking
for coffee in different ways.
And conceptualizing and
visualizing that flow
is really critical.
So she recommended that anybody
who starts designing a bot,
do not start designing it
without having a blueprint
of what you're designing for.
Here are the four things
I'm designing for,
and then these four flows
can look something like this.
And that is very
important to have.
And I think that's the
part we keep missing,
because we think that we know
how to have a conversation.
And this is what people
are going to ask my bot,
and we just end up developing.
BRIAN DORSEY: I'm
super new to this.
When you say, design
these blueprints,
I don't know what that
actually is or looks,
because I'm used to know
either code or scripts or HTML
or something.
What's the format
of these blueprints?
Is it just drawing
things out so you
have a good sense in your head?
Or what does it look like?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: I
asked the same question,
because we are a little more
developer-centric people.
So we think about
codes and scripts
and flowcharts--
things like that.
And she literally said
it can be any format
that you want it to be in.
It can be just a
simple script where
it's like the user's
going to say this
and the bot is going
to respond with this.
And the bot can respond
in these four ways
if the user says this question
in these different ways.
So it can literally be
any format you prefer.
It can be an Excel sheet.
It can be just a Word doc.
It could be in animated format
with pictures and stuff.
But the idea is that you
should have something
to go off of and not
just start coding.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
This is going to make
it super awkward the next time
I run into Brian in the hallway.
And I'm going to be like,
hold on, let me bust out
my spreadsheet because I need
to map out this conversation.
BRIAN DORSEY: You
don't do that already?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, yeah, do
you put that mental preparation
in?
Because I promise you I am
now self-conscious about being
able to have a conversation.
Priyanka's like,
most of us don't
know how to have conversations.
I'm like, yeah, of course.
Why else would I host a podcast?
I have no idea how to
have a conversation.
But what you're
saying is we need
some sort of flow of
dialogues, perhaps
in the form of a Dialogflow.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Did you
like that lead-in, by the way?
I thought it was cool.
[APPLAUSE]
Been working on it
for like three days.
So tell us a little bit more
about what Dialogflow actually
is.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Dialogflow is Google's tool
that is powered by
natural language
understanding and natural
language processing
to create rich and
natural conversations.
And what I mean by that
is it makes this process
simpler and easier.
When I said I can ask for
coffee in 1,000 different ways
depending on the day and
the mood and the time
and all of that, it's
nearly impossible
to gather all of those ways
in which 1,000 people are
going to ask for coffee.
But in a broader term, it's
easy to just lay it out.
And what Dialogflow does
is you put an intent in,
saying most common ways in
which people ask for coffee.
And then it would apply the
natural language understanding
and NLP on it and
comprehend some
of the other ways in
which people can actually
ask for coffee.
So I can say, I would
like some coffee.
And I can give 10
examples in there and say,
I would like some coffee.
Can I get some coffee?
It would be great to get
some coffee right now.
Amazing to get some
coffee right now.
Coffee sounds amazing.
These are some ways in which
I ask for coffee depending
on what the day is
and what my mood is.
I'm pretty sure Mark has
some very interesting ways
in which he can ask for coffee.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I mean, you're very
polite to your coffee-maker.
[LAUGHTER]
Now I feel bad.
I usually just yell
"coffee" at mine.
And it's not
voice-enabled, I just
am yelling coffee
while also wanting it.
BRIAN DORSEY: And with
deep apologies to everyone
listening to this before
they've had their coffee.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
No, I mean, if you haven't
had your coffee, please pause.
Go grab some-- ideally while
yelling the word, coffee.
And then come back to us.
[APPLAUSE]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yes.
So going back to it,
the power of Dialogflow
is you provide these
intents, and then it
would map some of the
others on its own.
Because it's powered with
natural language processing
and understanding,
it would understand
the other ways in which
people are asking for coffee.
So you don't have to provide
those 1,000 examples.
You can just provide
a few, and it still
understands the user's intent.
So that's one.
And then the other
power of Dialogflow
is you design your
bot experience once,
and you can enable it for
multiple different interfaces.
And that is the biggest
thing, because omnichannel
is a huge requirement
for enterprises,
because you want to make
sure that the experience
of the brand is similar
on every channel
that the user's
interacting you with.
So whether they're coming from
Facebook Messenger or Slack
or Google Home or Assistant
or just a web chat,
the experience should
be seamless and similar
across the board.
So that's the other power
you get from Dialogflow.
There's also languages.
So it's not that
you're only going
to support English or one
language in which you're
doing business today.
You have to think
about global expansion
and have multiple
languages supported.
So if you're doing
it by yourself,
it's going to be
really hard to support
all these different languages.
Dialogflow comes already
with 20 languages,
and we keep adding the
support based on our text
to speech and speech
to text offerings.
So that is, again,
very powerful.
And then it comes
with Analytics.
And that's always very useful.
The other very important aspect
is smalltalk and pre-built
agents.
So smalltalk is, as
you can imagine, like,
what's the weather like?
It comes with
pre-built smalltalk
so that you can just plug the
smalltalk portions and intents
into your bot
experience, so you don't
have to think about all the ways
in which people do small talks.
BRIAN DORSEY: Like
really chatty chat bots.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Exactly-- chatty chat bots.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Do
people respond well
to the small talky chat bots?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: It depends.
It depends on what the
persona of your bot is.
And that is a huge topic
around persona of the bot.
And you kind of
define that before you
start building your bot--
whether your bot is going to be
geeky or chatty or serious.
And once you define
that persona,
it might sometimes
make sense to have
small talk experience in there.
It usually makes it a little bit
more chatty but more friendly.
BRIAN DORSEY: Can we make a
bot that only does small talk?
SPEAKER 1: Welcome home.
It's been awhile, hasn't it?
You've certainly changed.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: I don't know.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
OK, so I'm inspired
to kind of play with this
and see some sort of coffee
experiments with bots.
And I'm sure other
folks listening are also
interested in digging in here.
How would you recommend
people get started, learn more
about this.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
So multiple different ways
and avenues to get started.
The first is definitely
some documentation
that we have on
www.dialogflow.com.
But then if you
don't like reading--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I'm listening.
Please, go on.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: --I
have a series of videos.
I have a series of
videos that I've
started from basically 101
called Deconstructing Chatbots.
It is on our YouTube channel--
Google Cloud YouTube channel.
There, you can actually get
started from what is a bot
and how do I design one
to actually building one
by yourself.
And then there are
labs that are in there
as well that you
can follow along
that point you to Codelabs.
And then the series is ongoing.
So you can catch up
and get to a point
where you can start to build
not just basic conversations
but also interact with more
Google Cloud Machine Learning
content.
So the episode that comes out
I think in the next two weeks
or so is actually building
a bot to understand invoices
when a user uploads their bill.
It's interesting, and
you can create these
while you are working
through videos along with me.
And you get the repository
and links as well.
So I would say that's
a good way to start.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I foresee Brian
in the next couple
of weeks making
small talk with his coffee pot.
BRIAN DORSEY: I'm
just going to try
to see if I can get it all the
way to grunt equals coffee.
Actually, in my
case, if I'm honest,
it's going to be hot tea.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, I
mean, that usually serves
a similar purpose, but no.
If I get up and I'm
just like, [GRUNT],,
I want that cup of coffee
right there ready for me.
BRIAN DORSEY: We
may have discovered
a deep, deep fundamental
philosophical difference
between us.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, with
the power of Dialogflow,
I'm sure you can
generalize it to say,
hey, I want my breakfast drink.
And then the AI will know.
BRIAN DORSEY: There we go.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So I think
we're just about out of time.
Priyanka, is there anything
else you want to mention?
We will have a link to the
Deconstructing Chatbots
playlist in the
description below the show.
But is there anything
else you want
to mention before we head out?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: I would
just say that these are really
easy to build experiences.
So give it a shot, just
like Brian is going to
in the next few weeks.
BRIAN DORSEY: I am signed up.
OK.
Everyone, please give it
a go, and thank you very
much for your time, Priyanka.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Thanks.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Thank you.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That
was a great conversation
with Priyanka.
I've played around a
few of these things.
Thankfully, she's got that
Deconstructing Chatbots
playlist, so I followed that.
And there's some
Codelabs on there
as well that have kind of
helped me play with it.
But there's a lot of aspects
to really thinking about
how people engage with chat
bots and what modeling that
looks like.
BRIAN DORSEY: I keep coming
back to all the different places
where you can interact
with the same back-end
that you build once.
So that just seems
really powerful,
as somebody who's used to
having to kind of write
different versions for
every new kind of front-end
that might show up.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
much more flexible
and a cool way to think about
creating a system, like you
said, and then reaching
all these different end
points, which is
great to meet users
in a lot of different ways.
BRIAN DORSEY: Meet
people where they are.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Speaking of
meeting people where they are,
we also have a really
cool way that I think
will help a lot of
people run some more very
common tasks in the cloud.
And the question is,
if I have a script,
like, for instance,
a Python script,
how do I run it in an
automated fashion--
like a recurring script?
Whether it's every
morning, three times a day,
how do I do that in the cloud?
BRIAN DORSEY: Oh, right,
so the kind of thing--
like on a Linux box, you
might use the cron scheduler
for hey, every third
hour, call this thing.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Right.
You could spin up
a Compute Engine
and then put cron on
there, but then you've
got to worry about
what happens if someone
wants to shut the box down
or you're wasting resources.
I mean, that doesn't seem like
a very scalable way to do it.
BRIAN DORSEY: Who
schedules the schedulers?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: There's a
terrible, terrible superhero
out there that I'm sure--
I don't think Cronman
is a very good--
but you know what?
He's always on time.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK, let's
move to the meat of this.
What is the recommendation
in this vlog?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, I
think that the question is,
using this Python
script, how do I run it?
And it looks like if we
run this with functions,
we've got some options to
use both Cloud Scheduler
and Pub/Sub.
But can you tell me
a little bit more
about how cloud scheduler works?
BRIAN DORSEY: Cool.
Yeah.
This article is written
by Kaitlin Ardiff,
who's one of our
strategic cloud engineers.
And it's really basically
saying Cloud Scheduler
handles the
scheduling part of it,
so a task that happens
on a regular basis.
And functions is the thing
we want to run in this case.
And using Pub/Sub, our
messaging queue that's
both high throughput
and very durable,
including retries and things
like that so it doesn't get
lost if the function has an
error or something like that.
And so you use Pub/Sub
as the kind of connection
between the two, which is
a really powerful model
for distributed
systems in general.
You've got a thing that is in
charge of policy, a thing that
is in charge of making sure
that it happens at least
once, and then a
thing that does it,
which seems like a
really great setup.
So it's a very nice,
succinct walkthrough
of this pattern that
is really common.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Exactly.
Right.
It gives this example
using specifically
a Python script
that runs BigQuery.
But at the same time, you've
got your Manage Cron service.
You've got a flexible
events handling system.
And then you can
pretty much do whatever
you want to do on the
actual execution side.
So this is a really
starter architecture
that can go out in a
lot of different ways.
In this case, they're
using Pub/Sub,
but you could also have
used HTTP for the functions,
but I think the authentication
would be a lot harder for that,
right?
BRIAN DORSEY: It
is now supported
in both scheduler and functions
to use the basic service
account.
And then you get the token
from the environment and kind
of pass that through the HTTP.
But I think that
going through Pub/Sub
is a much more general pattern.
And I think it lets you
plug other things in.
Like in this case,
maybe you're not
going to necessarily do
things off the same policy
of every other hour or
twice a day or something.
Maybe you are.
And then you can add
additional things listening
to that same Pub/Sub event.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
very flexible and a good way
to start working on something.
And the first time you build
it, you might be saying,
well, I don't know if I
need all these pieces.
Why not just keep it
very, very simple?
But as you extend
outwards, I think
you're going to find that having
built it in this flexible way
is going to make it a
lot easier down the road.
BRIAN DORSEY: I kind of
alluded to it at the beginning.
There's some non-obvious
stuff that's great.
If you have a direct
call and for some reason
there's a time-out or something
goes wrong that's a temporary
error--
if you're making
the direct call,
it will never happen again.
If you're working off
of a queuing system
and actually kind of
responding to those directly,
it'll make sure that it retries
it after failure and the like.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Very cool.
So all those details
are in the blog post.
Well, before we wrap up here,
Brian, what are you doing?
Where you going?
Doing any fun travels?
BRIAN DORSEY: So actually
I'm based in Seattle,
and I'm going to be
spending the next while
kind of hanging out
here in the office,
thinking about Compute Engine.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Just kind
of sitting and meditating
on Compute Engine?
[MEDITATION "OHMS"]
BRIAN DORSEY: Is it a slice
of a computer or a slice
of a data center?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh, no.
Wait, no, no, those
are deep questions.
Too much, too much.
Oh, well, I'll be traveling
to Austin next week--
[WHIP SOUND]
--to record with a
customer, hopefully
which will be a podcast
not too far from now.
Sticking around the Bay
Area to work on some up
and coming training videos,
which I think will be--
or the subject matter there
will be super helpful.
I know I can't say what
it is until it's out,
so I'm always like, oh,
I want to talk about it.
But I kind of can't.
But looking forward to, as
always, creating some really
fun content.
BRIAN DORSEY: Awesome.
Well, thanks for hanging out
with us all the way to the end,
everyone.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Very, very cool.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]